[Music]
seeing your son in such a dangerous
position obviously any parent would
fight to protect their kid at all costs
[Music]
defending Jacob tells the story of a
prosecutor who's 14 year-old son is
charged with the murder of a classmate
we have some bad news the print we
lifted from the victim's sweatshirt
it's from your son wait what
it's tricky when you're trying to create
a miniseries because you want to make
sure you schepis ode has a strong engine
and a purpose there's got to be an
explanation I didn't do it I swear
we begin to see his family tested and
she begins to question everything if any
doubts about Jacob sent us no of course
not
it's all about the family how they
experience it foundation is rocked it
says a lot of trust issues a lot of
guilt it kind of opens all those doors
how well can you ever know anyone and I
think this show forces us to think about
those boundaries that exist for the
people we learn once you open in doors
box
it's those scary corners you don't want
to explore it the twists and turns of
the thriller are fantastic but it's this
crisis of parenting that makes it unique
what are you willing to do as a family
how well do we know our children how far
we willing to go the interesting thing
about this show is that it's not shot as
a TV show it's shot like an 8 hour movie
I know you think you know Jacob but you
don't watch did he do this there's a
cliffhanger for every episode
I can't hand them over
Jacob how's he doing what do you think
this is a joke I can't play this game
anymore you doing
you
you